hey it's Greg that's right this face
again you might remember it from such
feature videos as how to use color and
other less popular ones anyways I'm back
because I've got a brand new color trick
that I really want to share with you so
today we are going to make a bunch of
color palettes using just one color
quick disclaimer this is by no means a
replacement for actually learning color
theory and developing your own
meaningful process for how to use it
however if after watching and hopefully
liking this video you do want to learn
more about it I teach a course about
this whole thing visit the future comm
slash color you can learn more about the
course you can sign up right there you
might like it I don't know okay
disclaimer over I think we can all agree
that color is hard and pairing colors
together that's even harder so where do
you start when you want to make a color
palette well think about the last time
you did what was your process and how
did it turn out
now you could start by googling color
theory and going down the Wikipedia
rabbit hole and there's a lot of cool
stuff but it's a lot of reading and not
much application that you can use
another option to consider is using a
palette generator or pulling from a
library like Adobe color but what
happens when you want to customize it or
you want to create something unique let
me show you what I mean start with a
color that you think you're probably
going to use now for this exercise I'm
gonna use this kind of red looking thing
here and I'm gonna name it rusty because
I like to name things make sure that
it's not too saturated and also that
it's not too dark because we need some
wiggle room to play with here so
somewhere in this general vicinity
should work just fine if our goal is to
make a color palette then our lone tone
is gonna need some friends now we could
simply add some tints and shades and
then call it a boring old day but that's
not why you're here you're here for
something new and exciting so let's do
it
the fun way and here's how that way
works visualize the Photoshop color
picker now imagine a line that starts
the top-left corner of it and then it
bends all the way down to the bottom
right passing directly through the color
you picked for old rusty here that line
might look something like this
basically the brighter a color gets the
less saturation it has and the darker
color becomes the more saturation we add
to it
now here's where things get interesting
and crazy and even a little dangerous so
not only are we going to follow an arc
but we're going to be changing the hue
as we move along let me show you what
that looks like
so to flesh out our pallet we're gonna
need at least four colors that are
lighter and four colors that are darker
remember the arc we're going to follow
this arc up into the left and if we go
dark we're gonna go down it to the right
so I want to go light so I'm gonna go up
a little bit and then over a little bit
and so we get lighter and we get less
saturated but then we're also gonna move
the hue up a little bit too so if we're
in this right here I'm just gonna nudge
it up just a little bit so it's kind of
orange II and we'll throw that bad boy
down and we'll do that three more times
to try to get a nice kind of like array
of color here going on and how much you
decide to move the hue is up to you but
I like options so I try to move it
enough so that I'm getting a pretty
different looking hue each time I go up
okay one more over here and adventuring
into two green a little bit okay cool
that's our light color now let's do the
same for our shades over here we're
gonna open this up we're going to go
down to the right following this kind of
arc trajectory and instead of moving up
again I'm gonna move the other way on
the color bar so if it's red I'm gonna
wrap it all the way back up around the
top we're gonna go venture into this
like purplish purplish looking place
here yeah that's cool now we want to be
careful not to get things too dark or
too crazy saturated and I will explain
why later here's what we've got which is
not entirely bad I don't hate it I mean
we could use this as our
or palate but that's kind of an
anticlimactic ending
don't you think so then how do we take
this further well one thing we can do is
add some more layers of value so I'm
gonna take this top part and select the
first like third of this and I'm gonna
open hue and saturation now as top part
will be the lighter colors so I'm gonna
bring the lightness up quite a bit and
then I'm also gonna bring the saturation
down so we kind of get into more like
pastel territory and that's cool now the
last little trick we're gonna do is
we're gonna slightly move the hue again
so in this case I'm gonna move it a
little bit to the left
just a touch not much looks good now
let's do the same thing for some darker
versions I'll select the bottom part
looking a hue saturation and in this
case we're gonna do the exact opposite
so we're gonna make our colors darker
right something like that and that's why
before I said hey make sure you don't
get too dark or too saturated because
otherwise this would just go pure black
and that's no fun these are darker we're
gonna add more saturation oh yeah look
at that and now we're gonna adjust the
hue but we're gonna do it in the other
direction so for the lights we went to
the left for the darks we're gonna go to
the right so just a little bit oh yeah
getting some some cool [ __ ] eyes over
there I'm just making sure there's
enough of a difference in value between
this middle one the brights and the
darks and I think we're good there we go
value now we're cooking with fire we've
got a beautiful range of color and value
to work with I think I think we're ready
to start building some pallets at last
we get to the fun part making some color
pallets there's no real rule for how to
do this but I like to keep in mind I'm
gonna need a kind of brighter color and
then a darker color to play off of so
let's make a few pallets and see what
happens I'm gonna start with trusty
rusty here and then let's let's go for a
complimentary color palette so we'll be
writing
Green and then I think we need a neutral
to throw in here and then maybe like one
really dark color that'll be our might
be our kind of darkest color cool that's
interesting all right let's make a
couple more so maybe instead of rusty we
go with this it's kind of yellow here
and I'm gonna I'm gonna pick up this
green again cuz I like how these work
together maybe a brown and this one
maybe we'll maybe we'll keep it soft so
we don't need this kind of high contrast
dark thing it's kind of an interesting
palette right there too
so here that's that sucker out of the
way but maybe we do want to make
something high contrast so I'm gonna I'm
gonna go extreme go over here
pick this deep purple and then maybe
pair it with this kind of you know
brighter yellow orange go Lakers and
then maybe we throw throw here like this
kind of bright neutral in there so we
got really high contrast and then maybe
we even put in like a like another kind
of like flavor over here yeah I like
that it's cool this is generally what I
do you know I'll just kind of explore
this and combine different colors and
find ones that I really like putting
together and they just kind of like feel
right depending on the on the kind of
theme of what it is I need the colors
for and here's the here's the coolest
part right if you really like a palette
you can you can take this and expand it
even more by just basically doing the
same exercise that that we did before
then look at that we have a wonderful
kind of like base palette to work with
and then we have these cool like levels
of value to to add to it now I know what
you're thinking okay these for sure we
know the video here your Casa be any
more color benedict to squeeze out this
exercise but as it turns out you thought
wrong
I've got one last trick I want to show
you that we can use with this just to
get a bit more mileage out of what we've
done here
sometimes when I'm what I'm feeling
saucy I will go in I'll make a new solid
color layer and I will apply it over my
colors here and then pick a really kind
of bright and saturated color and then
set its blending mode to overlay look
what happens that's crazy
Wow look at all these it's like a
brand-new set of colors right it's like
look at that and now look at it it's
really it's a really awesome way to kind
of just add another dimension and get
more variation out of out of these kind
of color swatches let's make a few color
palettes and I can show you just how
much mileage you can get out of out of
this
[Music]
what's the right decision it doesn't
matter
maybe we go here there's our black look
at how cool it is and so much different
than the previous one cool right I think
so but I'm also a huge nerd for color
now to give you an idea of how flexible
this whole process is here's a montage
of all the color palettes I came up with
from just this one exercise
[Music]
I hope this trick helps you get excited
about using color and fun and new ways
and hopefully making a few color
palettes of your own
remember teach a whole course about this
so if you really want to learn more
about it be sure and check that out I'll
put a link to the course in the
description just in case also if you
have a question about any of this or
color in general drop a comment here DM
me on Instagram whatever bakes our cake
thanks for watching and I will see you
[Music]